he said you bring it to an end by
bringing Ukraine into NATO but of course
we're a NATO country so if you bring
Ukraine into NATO that puts the United
States at War Megan said that to her and
then she basically gave a word salad as
to how you go from there there was a
debate last night on CNN uh as I said at
5:00 pm yesterday uh Chris Christie
dropped out his one supporter was upset
about that uh thec did not uh qualify so
he went on a podcast uh but Dan santis
and Nikki did and they got into it a
little bit uh here's the governor going
after Dicky
Haley she doesn't articulate how this
comes to an end except she was asked uh
after the last debate uh I believe Megan
Kelly and she said you bring it to an
end by bringing Ukraine into NATO but of
course we're a NATO country so if you
bring Ukraine into NATO that puts the
United States at War Megan said that to
her and then she basically gave a word
salad as to how you go from there so
they have sent cash uh she supports this
106 billion that they're trying to get
through Congress where's some of that
money going they've done tens of
billions of dollars to pay salaries for
Ukrainian government bureaucrats they've
paid pensions for Ukrainian retirees
with your tax dollars we've got homeless
veterans we have all these problems this
is the UN way of thinking that we're
somehow globalists and we have unlimited
resources to do you know I think here's
the problem you can take the Ambassador
out of the United Nations but you can't
take the United Nations out of the
ambassad all right I'm only going to
show you one or two more clips from the
debate but that everything he said there
was absolutely true right you can have
your own feelings on whatever you think
we should be doing or not doing with
Ukraine but nikk has been Allin on that
that we should endlessly arm them we
know we're giving them boatloads of
money we're paying for all these
pensions we have enough problems here
like make the clean case why we should
be there be pointed out in the previous
debate she couldn't even name three of
the provinces in Ukraine that she wants
to give money to okay fine so that that
was just a nice moment uh by Dan santis
another nice moment was they were asked
to compliment each other and I think
you'll see a little bit of a difference
in the way they both went about doing
that Governor Dan santis let me ask you
what do you admire about Governor Haley
well look I mean I think that um you
know at the United Nations um I did
think that she she spoke out strongly on
some key issues and I appreciated that I
also appreciate uh the state of South
Carolina my wife uh is a College of
Charleston graduate um her parents lived
there for many many years and so it is a
wonderful State uh there's a lot of
great people there um and I think to be
able to have been Governor there is is a
great achievement and um I uh really
appreciate everyone I've gotten to meet
in South Carolina governor Haley what do
you admire about Governor DeSantis I
think he's been a good
Governor
okay like Nikki come on and I like you
Nikki right like personally I like you
but like come on there's a bunch of
things he led on Co like Florida's free
low T like there's so much you could do
there he at least had the um the decency
to be like yeah she did a nice job at
the UN which by the way she did a
spectacular job at the UN right like I
think regard even even the most magga
crazy people who now hate her even
though Trump was the one that made her
the US ambassador to the UN they
acknowledged that she did a fine job uh
right
there